le sérieux d'un établissement vous avez
des charges fixes aujourd'hui c'est sûr
je fixe ne sont pas couverts là
aujourd'hui nous allons fermer et nous a
même pas un centime de recettes pour y
faire face parce qu'il faut savoir que
nous avons ouvert nos établissements
depuis le mois de juin avec 50 60
capacité ce qui ne permet pas ce qui ne
permet pas de couvrir les frais
aujourd'hui nous avons un mollet au
modèle économique
il ne tient plus donc aujourd'hui la
situation est très grave et je suis très
inquiet je pense que j'avais dit rendre
conscients de nos établissements
risquent de disparaître
mais aujourd'hui vous avez l'hôtellerie
quai derrière il va suivre et vous avez
je pense qu'on va arriver il démolit une
destruction de deux entreprises vers 40
concentre sur la totalité du territoire
mais en plus c'est le nombre de salariés
parce que nous avons quand même nous
sommes le chêne nous avait derrière nous
les restaurateurs vous avez les
agriculteurs vous avez toute une chaîne
alimentaire qui est très importante et
qui est elle mise à mal aussi
et ça c'est très très bien parce
qu'aujourd'hui je me demande dans quel
état on va sortir de cette crise et les
terriens venga frappe l'europe dans son
ensemble la situation est grave selon la
situer la présidente de la commission
européenne les vingt-sept se réuniront
aujourd'hui par visioconférence pour
faire le point hier charles michel le
président du conseil européen a appelé à
des actions communes écouter chaque jour
compte il faut maintenant une action
déterminée nécessairement d'envergure
européenne basée sur deux piliers le
testing racing et les vaccins comme la
france l'allemagne a décidé d'imposer un
nouveau tour de vis le pays a besoin
d'un effort national c'est ce qu'a
déclaré hier angela merkel
conséquence les bars restaurants salles
de sport cinéma théâtre devront fermer à
partir du 2 novembre prochain
on veut finir ce que nous savons
maintenant que nous devons réduire à
nouveau les contacts et donc réduire le
risque
que d'infection route abbring à sa prof
d'eps et c'est pourquoi nous avons
besoin d'un effort national dès
maintenant et à partir du 2 novembre
kraft en string en galère quelques a
également annoncé que ces mesures seront
assorties d'être jusqu'à 10 milliards
d'euros pour amortir le choc économique
d aide réclamée notamment par le monde
de la culture
dans la foulée des annonces plusieurs
milliers de personnes se sont
rassemblées en berlin en soutien à
l'industrie du divertissement et du de
l'industrie du divertissement
nous devons juste nous battre pour
survivre par ce concept période de
coronavirus nous avons tous le même
problème nous avons besoin d'argent et
nous voulons juste danser et le studio
est sur le point de mourir
nous luttons vraiment ce moment à cause
du virus qu'ovide nous ne recevons
aucune aide du gouvernement et nous
devons toujours payer notre loyer
intégral même si nous obtenons moins de
la moitié des revenus que nous
recevrions normalement et ailleurs dans
le monde la forte augmentation des cas
de virus inquiète les gouvernements de
plusieurs pays c'est le cas au maroc où
3985 nouvelles contaminations et 80
décès ont été enregistrés hier le pays
prépare la mise en place de tests
antigénique plus rapide pour augmenter
le nombre de dépistages à casablanca qui
recense le plus grand nombre de cas les
autorités veulent faire appel aux
personnels du privé en prévision de la
catastrophe annoncée dans les hôpitaux
de la ville lé mois prochain ce sujet
est peu détaillé prady vice président de
la fédération nationale marocaine de la
santé nous sommes à 3510 et surtout moi
je regarde beaucoup plus sur le
surnombre de décès plutôt que les
nouveaux cas positifs qui dépendent
énormément de la capacité de tester en
nous sommes à 3500 décès peut-être que
le mot moi de ne voir si la situation
continue de la même façon si on ne prend
pas des mesures ils sont un peu plus
drastiques que ça on aura 1800
dc au mois de novembre peut-être 4500
rentes et s'en est peut-être au mois de
janvier 2010 la société et il faut bien
sûr une action immédiate et urgente pour
pouvoir freiner cette épidémie qui
malheureusement avec ses désirs vague
qui s'annonce a beaucoup plu aux copies
brutale qu'on ait le procès sont les
états unis à cinq jours du scrutin
présidentiel la campagne entre dans sa
dernière ligne droite
à quelques heures d'intervalle donald
trump et joe biden tiendront des
meetings dans la même ville atteint pas
les tacles et de floride
au coeur des échanges entre les deux
candidats la crise sanitaire est les
etats-unis est le plus lourd tribut au
monde
on fait le point avec notre envoyé
spécial à new york à stéphanie de murs à
new york où je me trouve la vie n'est
plus là même le new york qu'on
connaissait tous avant qu'on ait
apprécié bien s'est terminée en tout cas
pour l'instant
certains quartiers vont être confiné à
l'instar de brooklyn et où le queens
confinement partiel et restaurants sont
quasiment tous fermés en tout cas on
peut difficilement trouver des
restaurants où l'on peut s'asseoir pour
dîner tranquillement il faut faire de la
vente à emporter ici les commerces
pareil tourner un régime très lent la
moitié des capacités seulement les new
yorkais traumatisés par les vingt-trois
mille morts lors de la première vague
quittent la ville faisant chuter les
prix de l'immobilier
on comprend ainsi pourquoi la crise
sanitaire est devenu l'un des tous
premiers sujets de cette campagne
présidentielle les démocrates jo by
d'honneur en tête en profite évidemment
pour tirer à boulet rouge sur la
stratégie de donald trump qui jugent
désastreuse
joe biden a d'ailleurs été reçu
aujourd'hui par les autorités sanitaires
nationales du pays pour le briefer sur
les crises sanitaires écouter joe biden
qui en a profité à nouveau pour
critiquer son adversaire républicain
nous avons déjà perdu plus de 220 milles
10 avec ceux des rues mais ce
gouvernement a baissé les bras
ce week-end est le chef de cabinet de la
maison blanche marc le doze a déclaré à
la télévision qu'ils agitaient le
drapeau blanc il avait rendu les armes
il a dit je cite nous n'allons pas
contrôler la pandémie fin de citation
le peuple américain mérite bien mieux
que cela regardez ce qui s'est passé la
nuit dernière à omaha après tron après
la fin du meeting de preuves des
centaines de personnes dont des citoyens
agissent et les enfants ça se sont
retrouvés coincés dans un froid glacial
pendant des heures des gens à l'hôpital
à cette image et le titille de toute la
gestion de crise du président truc qu'il
prend des engagements qu'il fait
beaucoup de grandes déclarations mais
elles ne tiennent pas la route
il fait sa séance photo il s'en va il
laisse à tous les autres les
conséquences de son absence de plan
sérieux j'irais bien que ça ne le
préoccupe il pose il reste au pouvoir -
il est responsable
ça suffit il est temps de changer un
hashtag cher à leur donner trop de bruit
n'est pas du tout d'accord avec cette
voix là ces critiques de la part des
démocrates ils pensent au contraire que
les restrictions trop ses vertus
l'économie et que ça fait finalement
beaucoup plus de dégâts que le virus
lui-même donald trump qui promet de son
côté que la pandémie sera bientôt
terminé et accuse son opposant mais
aussi les médias mainstream comme il dit
d'effrayer les américains et donc d'
exagérées pour gagner des voix et côté
nous avons eu affaire à des événements
violents d'or en mai était dans sa cave
et ils ont dit vous devez sortir de ce
sous sol
alors il a voyagé du delaware jusqu'à un
tout petit coin de la pennsylvanie juste
à côté
et elle a fait son discours et il a dit
qu'il ne faisait pas ce genre de meeting
à cause du coc vide
vous savez on ne les fait pas parce que
personne n'y vient c'est pour sa
personne
kovi kovi kovi c'est tout ce dont ils
parlent les médias de la désinformation
kovi kovi kovi c'est toi ce dont ils
parlent
les progrès que nous avons faits dans ce
domaine aussi comprenons nous savons que
nous devons protéger nos aînés et nous
les protégeons nous disposons des
meilleurs tests au monde
c'est pour ça que nous avons tant de cas
c'est parce que nous faisons plus de
tests que n'importe qui mais nous nous
en sortons très bien et oh excusez moi
mais je suis là je suis là aussi devant
vous alors on l'aura compris un les deux
candidats ont vraiment des stratégies
complètement opposés sur le sujet alors
que l'un continue à sillonner les états
unis donald trump est aujourd'hui en
arizona son opposant démocrates lui
reste toujours chez lui dans le delaware
pour dit il je cite ne pas générer
d'événements super propagateur en termes
de virus je tends ainsi on l'aura
compris une pierre dans le jardin du
locataire de la maison blanche
autre sujet au coeur de la campagne
américaine le racisme et les violences
policières
washington a connu une deuxième une
manifestation en soutien acquéreurs
hinton j'en afro-américain de 20 ans
décidée lundi à philadelphie après un
contrôle de police
hier soir les forces de l'ordre ont
lancé des gaz lacrymogènes pour
disperser la foule à philadelphie là où
tout a commencé un couvre-feu a été
instauré cette nuit après deux nuits
d'émeutes des manifestations violentes
suivies de saccage de plusieurs
commerces
trois jours après l'échec d'un cessez le
feu signé sous l'égide des etats-unis
nouvelle escalade des violences dans le
haut-karabagh l'armée azerbaïdjanaise a
diffusé de nouvelles images des attaques
de drones visant des militaires
arméniens
région réponse de bakou qui a plu à
erevan et d'avoir tué des civils dans
cette attaque deux missiles est les
bombardements auraient fait une
vingtaine de morts et plus de 60 blessés
dans la ville de barda selon les
autorités azerbaïdjanaises à des
violences démenti à part l'argument fait
le point sur la situation avec robin qu
elle la tension ne retombe pas dans le
haut-karabagh depuis deux jours bakou
accuse l'arménie d'opérer des tirs de
roquettes sur des populations civiles
dans la région de barda ville
azerbaïdjanaise frontalière du haut
karabagh sur les réseaux sociaux
les proches du président azerbaïdjanais
dénonce des frappes destinées à infliger
des blessures excessive parmi les civils
après ces événements ilham alief
souhaité rendre hommage aux victimes et
s'en prend à l'arménie
je demande à dieu de bénir ceux qui sont
morts à barda à la suite de l' attaque à
la roquette par les forces armées
arméniennes
je présente mes condoléances à leur
famille et souhaite aux blessés un
prompt rétablissement
la vengeance des habitants de barda ne
restera pas sur le terrain et les
représailles contre l'occupant auront
lieu sur le champ de bataille
l'azerbaïdjan a par ailleurs saisi la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
pour demander des sanctions contre
l'arménie et l'a sommé de mettre un
terme à ses bombardements sur des zones
civiles
de son côté erevan dément ces
accusations
le communiqué du ministère
azerbaïdjanais de la défense disant que
les forces armées arméniennes aurait
frappé la ville de barda avec des
roquettes smertch est faux et infondé
ces tensions interviennent alors qu'une
trêve humanitaire négocié par les états
unis était instaurée depuis lundi en
tout ce sont trois tentatives
successives de cessez-le-feu négocié
entre bakou et erevan à moscou paris et
washington qui ont volé en éclats dès
leur entrée en vigueur
les deux camps se rejetant la
responsabilité des échecs
la colère de la turquie après la une du
dernier numéro de charlie hebdo ou une
caricature du président turc recep
tayyip erdogan ankara annonce qu'elle
apparaît la pression judiciaire et
diplomatique et dans un langage car il
visualise la culture voiture combien
suite et le journal satirique qui était
pas mal évoque de son côté les vauriens
de charlie hebdo ce sont ses mots
ils accusent l'europe de s'en prendre à
l'islam pour dissimuler ses échecs en
connectique est elle vécue et du chemin
je crois que les ennemis de la turquie
et de l'islam sont allés se noyer dans
un marais de haine et d'animosité au nom
de la liberté c'est le signe que
l'europe est revenu à des temps barbares
initiale du soulman met une touche man
nous demandons à ceux qui utilisent
l'hostilité anti musulmane et turcs pour
dissimuler leurs échecs en politique
intérieure de retirer leurs mains sales
de nos valeurs sacrées cheikh mesdames
messieurs
est-ce que nous renoncerons à notre
honneur pour eux allons-nous détourner
le regard face à eux
certains pourraient le faire mais le
peuple turc ne peut pas adopter une
approche immoral face à une attaque
contre sa foi et ses valeurs le
président turc à qui dénonce un lynchage
comparé comparable à celui des juifs
durant la seconde guerre mondiale
pourtant lorsqu'on se penche sur les
différents épisodes de sa carrière
politique l'humanitaire ne semble pas
toujours avoir été au coeur de ses
préoccupations et tous les musulmans ne
sont pas logés à la même enseigne
l'édito de qui arrive quotidien on sait
depuis longtemps que ratchet tayyip
erdogan se pose en homme fort sur le
plan géopolitique refusant les
concessions il met en avant la puissance
de son pays quitte à parfois éveillé
indignation mécontentement ces
polémiques plus de son temps après ils
refusent toujours de reconnaître le
génocide arménien qui a pourtant fait de
1,2 à 1,5 million mort de manière
parfaitement documenté aujourd'hui son
soutien envers l'azerbaïdjan dans le
conflit qui l'oppose à ces mêmes
arménien
est un mystère pour personne reste qu à
l inverse des azerbaïdjanais les
arméniens sont chrétiens ce qui tendrait
à accréditer la thèse d'un air de ran
champion du monde musulman
une thèse qui veulent vite en éclats
quand on se penche un peu sur la
question en 2019 frère de ran menacé
d'écraser la tête des kurdes pourtant en
première ligne du combat contre des shu
menées par une coalition censée être
allié d'ankara
s'il ne se retirait pas des zones
frontalières de la turquie promesse
tenue puisque la répression militaire
contre les kurdes à la frontière turco
syrienne avait été rude les violences
envers les forces kurdes en syrie était
bien réelle elle avait fait au bas mot
150 morts cette opération s'était
adjointe de l'installation de deux
millions de réfugiés sur les terres
kurdes
l'écrivain français patrice franceschi
qui a effectué de nombreuses missions
humanitaires dans la région avait alors
parlé de nettoyage ethnique
le mois dernier alors que la perspective
d'une présidentielle anticipée prenait
de l'ampleur en turquie et que le parti
d'erdogan semblait en perte de vitesse
plus ou moins 30%
ce dernier a multiplié les actions
contre le parti politique opposant kurde
uhd paix à ne pas confondre avec le pkk
partisans de la violence
en procédant à pas moins de 80 2
arrestations de militants de ce parti
raison invoquée avoir en 2014 donc il y
a 6 ans maintenant appeler les turcs à
descendre dans la rue en signe de
protestation alors que la ville kurde de
coban et subissait le siège de dèche
en turquie les cures ne sont pas les
seuls à être l'objet des foudres
d'erdogan
rappelons que le coup d'état manqué de
2016 a donné le coup d'envoi de purges
impressionnant dans tous les pays ont
été visés
l'armée ces putchistes bien sûr mais
également ses opposants intellectuels
universitaires artistes ou journalistes
en juin l'assemblée parlementaire du
conseil de l'europe estimait que 95
d'entre eux étaient actuellement
emprisonné en turquie à tous les
tribunaux ne font pas de cadeaux mi
juillet on recensait plus de 2500
personnes condamnés à la perpétuité et
diverses peines de prison pour 1600
autres suspects depuis le coup d'état de
plus de soixante dix sept mille
personnes ont été incarcérées selon les
échos et plus de cinq cent dix mille
gardes à vue ont été prononcées pour
soupçons de soutien au coup d'état
pas sûr que les yéménites n'ont plus
perçoivent totalement les aspirations
humanitaire d'erdogan qui soutient
l'intervention saoudienne contre les
rebelles chiites houthis qui a fait
depuis 2000 15 cent mille morts selon
nombre d'estimations et a été qualifié
de pire catastrophe humanitaire au monde
à l'onu alors air d'orane champion des
musulmans c'est peut être vrai pour
certains mais sans doute moins s'ils ont
le malheur d'être kurdes ou chiites ou
tout simplement opposant recep tayyip
erdogan veut vraiment être la figure de
proue du monde musulman éléments de
réponse avec 4 blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales il est entré
en concurrence avec l'arabie saoudite et
dans une certaine mesure également avec
l'egypte où la mort cela moxxi la
mosquée el aqsa tient un peu le rôle
dominant en matière en matière de
religion sunnites et qu' il veut
apparaître comme le leader des musulmans
sunnites
et ces gens là pour ça qu'il a eu une
réaction aussi violente après le
discours de d'emmanuel macron à la
sorbonne après la mort atroce de ce
professeur français d'histoire une
réaction violente qui le pousse à
dénigrer la france a critiqué de façon
personnelle son président de la
république provoquant d'ailleurs ce
qu'il ce qu est l inverse de ce qu'ils
souhaitaient une prise en mars de
l'union européenne en faveur de monsieur
macro et la france
reste que la population la population
turque ne semble pas très disposé à
suivre toutes les fantaisies de monsieur
erdogan
elle voit bien que les conditions
économiques et sociales se dégrade et il
n'est pas sûr que ces consigne de
boycottage des produits français soient
suivies en est les propos d' emmanuel
macron lors de la cérémonie d'hommage à
samuel pâtit continue de provoquer des
contestations hier devant l'ambassade de
france à téhéran des iraniens ont
manifesté contre l'insistance de paris à
soutenir les caricatures ils étaient
munis d' affiches représentant emmanuel
macron en diable de même au pakistan à
karachi
protestataires ont piétiné une photo du
président français ils ont également
incendié une effigie de lui devant
l'ambassade de france des rallyes fait
station qui se multiplient dans
plusieurs pays mouvements
c'est bien simple en libye des petits
groupes se sont rassemblés samedi dans
plusieurs villes et des internautes
avaient même appelé à manifester
dimanche sur la grand place des martyrs
à tripoli
des portraits des manuels macron et des
drapeaux français ont été piétinées et
brûlé pour manifester leur colère la
plupart des contestations se sont
déroulées devant les ambassades
françaises samedi environ 200 personnes
se sont massées devant la résidence de
l'ambassadeur de france en israël et
dans la bande de gaza des manifestants
ont brûlé des photos du président
français plusieurs rassemblements ont
également eu lieu dans le maghreb dans
la localité tunisienne d'el qu'amour aux
portes du sahara un défilé anti france a
rassemblé dimanche quelques dizaines de
personnes
et comme dans d'autres pays des appels à
boycotter les produits français se sont
répandues sur les réseaux sociaux
tunisiens au maroc le ministère des
affaires étrangères condamne fermement
la poursuite de la publication des
caricatures outrageuse à l'islam et aux
prophètes de manière symbolique en syrie
un appel au boycott des produits
français a été lancé en irak
le parti rabat à la dernier né des
factions armées pro iran affirme être
prête a répliqué après ce qu'elle a
qualifié d' insulte à un milliard et
demi de personnes et dans le reste de
l'actualité en bref et en images le
vietnam frappée par le typhon mollahs
pour moins 25 personnes sont mortes et
des dizaines sont portées disparues dans
des glissements de terrain selon les
autorités locales c'est le pire typhon
jamais vu depuis ces vingt dernières
années
s'agit du quatrième phénomène de son
joueur à frapper en quelques
en pologne les forces de l'ordre ont
délogé hier soir magnette militari des
manifestants regroupés devant le
parlement
des centaines de personnes s'étaient
réunies pour protester contre les
restrictions du droit à l'avortement
il ya une semaine le tribunal
constitutionnel a rendu un verdict
interdisant l interruption volontaire de
grossesse en cas de malformations graves
du foetus
seuls demeurent autorisées les
avortements en cas de viol d'inceste ou
de danger pour la vie de l'arrière des
bus des élections législatives en bien
malien vat anticipé pour certaines
tranches de la population est la dame de
rangoon où la dérision civile anne
sophie qui a voté ce matin elles cinq
ans après son arrivée au pouvoir dans le
pays son parti la ligue nationale pour
la démocratie devrait remporter ce
scrutin prévu le 10 novembre
alors j'ai rien mais j'ai des tabous
tebboune a été transféré hier soir en
allemagne pour des examens médicaux
approfondis
un déplacement qui intervient après
l'annnonce de cas suspect de provident
19 dans l'entourage du chef de l'état
samedi le gouvernement avait fait savoir
que l'oeil de 74 ans était mis
volontairement à l'isolément pour cinq
jours après la contamination des hauts
responsables de la présidence et du
gouvernement
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité dans une trentaine de
minutes en compagnie de sophie dans mon
couturier très bonne journée à tous
là sur arte france
[Musique]
il semble qu'il existe une architecture
naturel reposant sur le pli quel
avantage la nature aux rétais la
pratique et l'origami et comment
peut-elle produire des schémas de
pillage aussi complexe l'évolution a dû
revenir les systèmes de plis parce que
cela permet de développer de très
grandes surfaces à l'intérieur de tout
petits espaces ce n'est donc pas
surprenant de voir de l'origami dans les
selles d'insectes et dans les feuilles
dans l'intestin
on peut même voir des système de pliage
semblables sur le cortex les objets
inspirés par les origamis surgissent
déjà dans notre quotidien
[Musique]